welcome to camp et thank you for having
me dude so this is my first VidCon is it
you're lying to me swear first VidCon
what numbers is for you just 2012 so
forth I remember coming to my first
playlist live that was in 2011 and one
person stopped me but then I saw I just
seen lines and I saw this person line up
Freddie Wong is I am like the day I get
to that level I'm gonna stop and talk to
every single one of them so can have you
heck yeah yeah do we need to talk about
some very very exciting news I mean come
on you obviously your videos are known
for the animation and now it's paying
off
paid off no something's like so you're
heard of show Bob's Burgers rings a bell
I mean we're doing a movie together
essentially I'm just gonna cut right to
the chase
Wow the heaviiy peeing directing and
writing so it's like no pressure you
know I'm very anxious to see how I can
integrate marketing it from my YouTube
to the movie itself like these are
deadlines like when is the Halloween
where's the candy at chocolate Oh see I
use nasty sell these at high school
really I had a side hustle bro I'm a
businessman you're a hustler that's how
you got to Bob's Burgers I let me get a
ring pops - done I'm gonna go propose to
somebody right I love it all right well
we're gonna start coloring thanks for
watching guys